look the left and the right agree on
this that we know there's an age of
retirement and an age at which people
start to deteriorate yet our government
is run exclusively by you know
septogenarians and octogenarians maybe
maybe with all due respect these these
people should be given an opportunity to
retire off into the sunset and just to
relax with the coconut and a cigar or
something if you ever heard of uh El
Presidente Salazar of Portugal this is a
can I tell you it's a very quick story
but this is one of my favorite stories
so uh Portugal had one of those
presidents for life like in I think it
was in the 60s or the 70s but he's like
El Presidente but he's he's a dictator
right he has a stroke and he is on his
deathbed in the rubber stamp parliament
of Portugal goes all right enough of
this nonsense it's time to go back to
being a democracy let's join the rest of
Europe we're going to be a liberal
democracy uh okay everybody all in favor
we're we're a democracy but then he
recovers and they go oh oh oh oh but
he's like he's okay but he's kind of
winded so what they do is they send him
to like the presidential Winter Palace
and for the next three years of his life
they don't tell him he's been ousted and
they send in lying orderlies to come in
every day and go ah yes Mr President we
did as you said and we firebombed Lisbon
or whatever and they just give him like
a like he's living in Truman's show for
three the last three years of his life I
think it's a great thing to do with
dictators give up give him uh give him a
fake send off yeah that's what they do
in Napoleon I mean they knew they can't
Marta the guy that's new though he knew
he was he didn't realize he didn't think
he was running Paris that would have
been funny oh yeah he knew he was he
knew he was yeah that's why a lot of
people recommended that or a lot of the
left was saying about Trump you know put
him in a fake White House and then just
film it into a reality show where he
thinks he's President part of me thinks
that's what's happening with Biden you
know like he's sitting there thinking
he's playing video games but Kamala
handed him a controller that's not
plugged in and she's exactly the one
doing it you have it backwards yeah the
American people are being shown a TV
screen it's so true and they're and
we're being told he's the president yeah
yeah well exactly I mean I'm pretty sure
things are being run by the people
around him the man can't finish his
sentence well I don't I don't you know I
I've said that several times I think the
people around him are trying to do what
Biden wants but a man that incoherent
makes it impossible so they're all you
know the joke is like they're all
sitting around the table and you know
and you've got uh Millie and like Kamala
and then Biden's like oh this uh it's
Ukraine thing yeah come on man did you
get a uh what come on man and then
they're all sitting around looking at
each other like uh what do we do what
did he say he wants us to do and then
Trump was like you guys got Vladimir
Putin you get him on the phone and shoot
another shot with a pressure and they're
like okay and then they all get up and
leave the room they're all looking each
other like what are we supposed to do I
have no idea what did he say and then
they just start pressing random buttons
like we're working Biden so they're
technically the ones doing things but
it's like without without a nucleus
without a cohesive core guiding you like
you know for all of Donald Trump's
faults he was telling people to do
things you know and they would do them
and things worked out now Joe Biden is
muttering to himself at the time and
they're just pressing random buttons
hoping something happens look you look
at the Afghanistan withdrawal who in
their right mind would be like we're
going to withdraw from the Bagram Air
Force Base in the middle of the night
without telling the Afghan Security
Forces then we're going to try and
evacuate people through the civilian
airport once everyone's found out hold
on if if our main goal is just to do it
on the anniversary of 9 11 if that's the
top goal it makes sense if you're just
doing it for symbolic purposes if that's
your top your top people I I think I
looked at the 2020 election and I
thought America had a choice between uh
getting on a train that keeps getting
lost or getting on a train that hits
cows for fun I I thought it was a really
really bad uh choice that we all had to
make on that one this is the problem
with um first past the post voting
systems yes yeah you end up with two two
people and everyone just hates the other
one so much they vote for the other one
and you end up with you know look in
2016 I was like I'm not voting for Trump
and Hillary Clinton yeah right I'm
definitely not voting for Hillary
Clinton when 2020 came around with
critical race Theory and everything that
was going on and then Trump released his
uh uh you know second term campaign
positions I was like I'll vote for that
you know it's it's not so bad what would
can you like because I I'm unfamiliar
with your your whole Arc I know that you
used to be a Bernie guy right oh yeah so
he's already lost his mind so okay so so
it like I wondered if maybe it's just
you're a populist and probably is that
it oh Bernie Sanders in 2015. open
borders is the Koch brothers proposal so
you know look I've got this on behalf of
the neoliberal shills we rather like
open borders we've been in favor of that
for a while so with Bernie you've got a
guy who's supported by a lot of working
class guys he says on stage a debate the
gun control debate is an urban versus
rural issue and people in Vermont like
guns so it's not Democrat Republican or
whatever there are Democrats or like
guns and I'm like you know I appreciate
hearing this because I think and and
back then I was not a staunch you know
2A absolutist for the most part I was
like I think there's some reasonable
discussion there but it felt it felt
reasonable because I know that people
who live in rural areas have a different
expectation on guns so I lived in um on
in in rural you know outside of Miami in
the Redlands back in I think this was
2015. and so I understood what was going
on in the neighborhood as to why people
liked guns there were illegal immigrants
who were committing crimes and killing
people and it happened in in this area
and so all of a sudden I'm like I I
think I understand why people are having
these conversations but Bernie Sanders
you know just quickly went full-on
neoliberal Dem Democrat establishment
Hillary Clinton open borders and I was
like I don't even know what the guy
stands for at this point nothing having
a bunch of houses and saying if you want
to have several houses you can write a
best-selling book
Donald Trump was a blowhard he was
bombastic but uh with 2020 you have his
push against critical race theory he
banned not explicitly critical race
Theory but the tenets of CRT which
violate the 1964 Civil Rights Act he
banned that from government contracts
and in government training which was
really really good I knew Biden would
overturn that and once again bring
racist whites like overtly white
supremacist ideology segregation back
into government under the guise of not
being white supremacist and they would
accuse the people who are fighting for
civil libertarianism of being the racist
so I'm like that's one for Trump Trump's
had a timeline for what's wrong out of
Afghanistan I said I'd like to see that
followed through look at what Biden did
hey I was right to vote for Trump Joe
Biden screwed that up miserably Donald
Trump is also forced didn't Biden delay
the timeline he delayed the title of the
timeline and then he screwed up the
withdrawal outright okay so Donald Trump
surrender how do you think you rendered
the difference than what Trump would
have done in terms of Afghanistan so so
uh there's a question why even Bill
Maher mentioned why didn't Vladimir
Putin invade Ukraine under Trump
Donald Trump was a Madman is a Madman uh
to the point where the left said he's a
madman and the right was like he's a
madman and I'm like I think we all agree
he's a Madman but um you know in varying
ways right the right was like he's he's
eccentric and he's gonna do it he's
gonna do shocking things uh Trump said
recently that he was talking to Putin
and said if you go into Ukraine I'll
I'll hit Moscow I'll nuke Moscow and
he's like hey he believed me a little
bit maybe five ten percent but it's
enough right I don't like that idea that
our president's going to be like I'll
kill 10 million civilians
but then you look at you know what Trump
was actually doing during this whole
conflict we saw the crushing of Isis
which Russia was probably like okay well
you know this guy's not crushing my
allies like the the Obama Administration
was doing with Syria and basically
arming the rebels in the Middle East
when he was talking about withdrawing
from NATO which would be very pleasing
to Russia right so if I was Russia and
the president was talking about
withdrawing from NATO I would not want
to antagonize NATO but I wouldn't want
to give them a rationale except if you
if you understand Trump you understand
he plays What's called the big ask what
Trump was saying and many argue he saved
NATO Trump went to Nato and said you're
not paying your fair share for military
and you're expecting the American people
to do it I hear that and I'm like I I
that is right that is true I'm
absolutely sick of the USB they all have
the the social welfare programs they
have is because they don't have the
military we have and then military and
if Russia encroaches on them we have to
foot the bill for them while the people
here crap you know talk crap about us
because look at those countries and
everything they get it's like yeah
because our troops are over there and
they shouldn't be what ends up happening
is they start paying a little bit more
what did Trump say when he went to he
went to this Nano meeting and he said
Germany you're dependent on Russia why
is the U.S footing the bill for NATO to
protect you from Russia and then you're
dependent on their oil keep doing deals
with them he was right about all that so
the reason why I think Vladimir Putin
didn't invade Ukraine partly is because
Trump is a bit
what's the right word for unpredictable
and a little crazy right erratic erratic
good work erratic okay and so Putin
genuinely I would imagine to a certain
degree was probably like I'm not sure
what he would do if I made these moves
now Biden he's predictable but with
Donald Trump you get the crushing of
Isis
Syria is Russia's Ally we don't like
Isis the United States liked Isis the
government did because it was
destabilizing the Assad regime and the
United States and Western Powers wanted
to build a pipeline through Syria so it
was also convenient for the West to be
like uh oh we accidentally gave weapons
to a bunch of jihadis trump goes in and
blows them all up you can say For Better
or For Worse the drone strikes and all
that stuff but Isis was decimated under
Trump so of course Vladimir Putin isn't
invading the one way these left these
leftists like to put it is they're like
because Trump was playing to Putin's
agenda and I'm like crushing Isis
staying out of Ukraine's Affairs and
actually like allowing things to
semi-stabilize like the Abraham Accords
oh it's no wonder Putin was so upset but
if you're if you're like that's Putin's
agenda what's your agenda war war in
Eastern Europe War in the Middle East I
don't want any of that I don't think we
should be the World Police so when I saw
what Trump was doing I said I like these
things it's enough for me to vote for
though with he Trump tried getting our
troops out of Syria you know what
happened a high-ranking official lied to
the American people about how many
troops were in Syria to keep them there
it's insane that is our
commander-in-chief saying the American
people want our troops out and I'm going
to make it happen and they said yeah
don't worry Trump there's only 200 left
Trump tried getting them all out and
they said we can't do it because of the
oil so Trump publicly comes out and says
we're going to keep 200 people in there
you know uh for the oil and he blurts it
out and I'm like good tell people what
we're doing there and why we're doing it
you know what happens one of the first
things one of the first reports we get
when Biden gets back in office is that
U.S troops started moving through Syria
again do you think Vladimir Putin was
happy about that but Syria is an ally of
Russia and and Russia as a naval base in
Tartus so when the U.S is in a country
that Russia has allied with it's not
surprising that Putin's gonna be like
you know fire Z missiles or whatever so
look Donald Trump far from perfect for a
lot of ways I believe that he represents
the worst of American culture you know
talking privately on a bus or whatever
about what you know women let you do it
you know all of these things are crude
and crass he does not represent the
office very well in terms of decorum but
when you look at how corrupt the
Democratic establishment has been and
are today and how they've kicked off all
of this conflict
I think Donald Trump would have been uh
the much better choice I believe that if
Donald Trump was still in office the
Afghanistan withdrawal would have gone I
wouldn't say swimmingly but much much
better I don't believe those couldn't
have gone much worse no I don't know it
was a surrender he's surrender no no U.S
surrendered Joe Biden surrendered Joe
Biden's Administration abandoned the
Bagram Air Force Base in the middle of
the night without notifying the Afghan
Security Forces when The Afghani Marines
were fighting for their lives Joe Biden
did nothing to assist them in fact they
didn't even know what Biden was doing
whenever I abandoned an Air Force Base I
always text always everything just so
you FYI FYI 11 pm I'm going away Andrew
it's it's it's it's considered proper to
do it in person you know you know what
I'm in life I tend to ghost I know
you're not saying
I'm like I don't really like Canada
anymore I'm just it'll figure it out
it'll figure it out take a look at
Keystone Pipeline getting shut down so
anyway back to uh thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in Monday through Friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there